Qui veux le croissant le plus plat de l'histoire?
Ce croissant est passé sous une voiture.
Qui veut ce croissant ?
Générique
Ok cool !
Voilà !
Aujourd'hui nous sommes au studio de l'olivier dans un grand fond blanc,
et on tourne mon cours métrage qui s'appelle La Porte Du Sommeil.
Let's Go !
Cette porte est la Porte du sommeil
Qu'on a fait construire par des très très gros décorateurs
et j'suis assez content
C'est exactement ce que j'imaginais.
*Clap*
Action !
- Faut que je m'endorme ! Non !
Bon...
Tout est à refaire
Plus tu t'énerves et moins tu pourras entrer.
Et j'ai niqué le décooor
Je vous présente Camille,
qui est une amie comédienne,
qui va jouer le rôle de ma femme, on peut le dire!
Et donc voilà on partage un peu le lit dans ce film...
Sauf que moi je suis un gros insomniaque et elle, elle dort comme un petit bébé...
Je sait qu'on s'en fout mais dans la vie j'suis insomniaque
Ah ouais ?
Ah on va devoir annuler le rôle...
Une comédienne siouplait ?
s'il vous plaît ? Euh, SVP ?
Qu'est ce que ça te fait, d'être la personne la plus chanceuse en caleçon ?
C'est vrai que je suis le plus chanceux pour une fois...
En caleçon et en slip en dessous attention!!
Moi je sais faire le bruit du ver de terre
Alors là on fait un plan très important dans l'histoire
C'est à dire que tout d'un coup
J'ai réussi à évacuer les mauvaises idées, les mauvaises pensées et l'insomnie disparaît
Et donc forcément du coup , les portes du sommeil s'ouvrent
A la manière de Jurassic Park, ce fameux plan où paaf
Les deux grosses portes s'ouvrent et laissent entrer les voitures dans le parc des dinosaures
Whaaaaaou
Silence !
Vas-y, vas-y !
Ouais !
T'es un peu content , tu souris, tu rigoles
D'accord ?
Nan, j'vais crier !
Ah, ah, ah !
Cette personne est Malo
5 ans.
Euh, acteur professionnel.
Qui joue : moi quand j'étais petit
Hein Malo ?
Alors par contre , pour prendre des petits Kinder chocobons la y'a du monde
Hein ?
Est ce que tu me passes un bonbon ?
Merci.
Ça t'est jamais arrivé de retrouver un objet de quand t'étais petit
Sauf que maintenant tu peut lire ce qu'il y a écrit dessus
Quand j'étais petit j'avais la même voiture,
Mais je savais pas que c'était écrit Construction dessus
(Rires)
J'voyais juste un sigle
Donne moi ma voiture travaux !
Tu la veux ?
Ouais c'est la mienne !
Hop la! Allez la !
Je suis actuellement avec Isabelle et Sam.
Qui sont deux comédiens
De qualité
Qui jouent mes parents quand j'étais plus jeune
Et ils font également de la musique, ils ont un groupe qui s'appelle Mini Vagues
Mini Vagues (Rires)
J'ai oublié
Allez écoutez
3, 2, 1, Let's Go !
J'suis avec mon poto.
L'homme poteau !
Hein,  c'est vraiment un homme poteau...
Pour le déplacer faut faire comme ça...
*beatbox*
Ça calme hein ?
Le mec qui fait l'homme instrument
*beatbox*
*impro batterie*
Mesdames et Monsieurs c'est une fin de tournage !
Sous titres fait par Sabrina Hamidi et corrigés par Solal Ledru